county leaders will hold an emergency
meeting this is tomorrow to discuss ways
of addressing the sharp rise in covid
cases locally for now
health leaders say everyone should
consider wearing a mask while in crowded
indoor spaces it's a recommendation that
is not a mandate
joe mohler speaking to people today
about the recommendations joe joins us
live near
uh well his location is di indicator
there it is joe take it away
yeah not everyone wants to put these
masks back on and other people say
they don't mind putting them back on we
did speak to some shoppers today who say
when they go out in public they're not
really noticing much of a difference
people are not wearing a mask i mean we
know that the bavarian is out there
as cases go up the health district wants
more people to mask up in public
i think it's actually less less people
are actually wearing masks with the
recent recommendation to wear masks
indoors the shoppers i spoke with
haven't noticed a difference i don't
know if they're watching the news or if
they're really paying attention to
what's going on
but we know the bearing is out there we
know it's changing it's
mutating everything some resorts are
requiring employees to wear masks once
again regardless of vaccination status
when people do come in as in today we do
put our masks on james kerr owns boss
security screens in the southwest valley
he says the masks add on an extra level
of safety
we're in the business of safety and
security to begin with so it makes sense
that
we're going to take extra precaution
some still think if you are vaccinated
you should not
need to mask up i have both of my
vaccine shots so i don't think i need to
but for people who don't i feel like
they
if they don't have the shot they need
their vaccine others don't think
vaccination status matters and wouldn't
mind seeing a mandate
again i would but i don't think i don't
think people are going to follow
anything until
until there's more deaths
back out here live we also did take this
topic to social media we asked people if
they started to wear this mask after the
recommendation and more than 50 percent
say they are starting to wear them
indoors
we also ask people if they feel safer
out in public indoors
less than 50 percent said they don't
feel any different reporting live at di
indicator joe muller 8 news now
joe thanks for that if you need to get a
coveted test this week there are several
locations available across the valley
you can head to the csn north las vegas
campus
also the campus on west charleston or
the henderson location
all of that testing by the way is going
to start on tuesday that's near the 95
and college drive also as you take a
look at the graphic here
brimley and fess middle schools will be
open for testing this week
for more information you can visit our
website at 8newsnow.com